for any picture it takes countless
strikes to cement a legend but what if I
told you that for one man all it took
was a single pitch on an overcast May
afternoon in 2009
Gary baba booey Dell'Abate stroke
confidently to the Citi Field pitcher's
mound it was the middle of a three-game
set for the Mets against the rival
Pittsburgh Pirates and Dell'Abate was to
throw out the ceremonial first pitch in
my opinion throwing out our first pitch
is just a bad idea if it goes well
nobody cares but if it goes badly it's
something that can haunt you for the
rest of your life if you were there that
day you could feel the energy in the
stands it saw the ball leave his hands
didn't really think anything of it but
then it became immediately clear
this is the worst throw in the history
of balls
Oh as I was walking around all the
security guys which I knew pretty well
would come to me did you see bobble
buoys first pitch and absolute disgrace
there's not supposed to be crying in
baseball but there was that day it was
wet ugly crying if you look at the
mechanics behind a pitch like that it's
pretty depressing that the human body
can do the stench of human failure all
over Citi Field that day for those in
the Mets organization Dell abates pitch
remains a difficult topic I hit the
bottle pretty hard after that after
witnessing such failure you can't help
but look at life and say what's the
goddamn point I would want to can go to
a small island somewhere never come back
here the media had a field day it seemed
everyone had something to say about Dell
abates notorious toss like it was a
double cup because Gary threw the ball
incredibly soft right and nowhere near
the auto-fire
my record the ball catches like I'm
gonna get up again catch a game that but
how did it come to this
how did we as a people get to this point
in history it all began in 1910 when
president William Howard Taft threw out
the ceremonial first pitch at a
Washington Senators game
I'm sure if Taft realized the fallout of
his actions 99 years later I think he
would have just said you know what I'm
gonna put the ball in my pocket and say
later Gator nearly a century later
Gary's pitch had an equally profound
effect on all bore witness coach
Dell'Abate was my little league coach
Tommy all of his techniques his secrets
I guess looking back on it now you know
I never really stood a chance though the
page has influenced thousands who have
followed in Dell'Abate footsteps no one
can seem to match the sheer gravitas of
the original to this day there are those
who call upon Dell'Abate to return to
the site of his legends birthing and to
give that first pitch a second shot if I
was Gary I think I might want to do it
again I think I might want to give her
another shot it'd be like a Sports
cleanse it can't go any worse he's hit
rock bottom with this one thing remains
certain Gary Dell'Abate has become a
symbol of America's two favorite
pastimes baseball and hang up would I do
it again No
you